one term you're going to hear a lot of
in these videos and in linear algebra in
general is the idea of a linear
combination linear combination and all a
linear combination of vectors are oh
they're just a linear combination I mean
let me show you what that means so let's
say I have a couple of vectors v1 v2 and
it goes all the way to VN and there are
Lynn you know can be an r2 or RN let's
say that they're all they're all in RN
you know they're in some dimension of
real space I guess we could call it but
the idea is fairly simple a linear
combination of these vectors means you
just add up the vectors it's some
combination of the sum of the vectors so
v1 plus v2 plus all the way to VN but
you scale them by arbitrary constants so
you scale them by c1 c2 all the way to
CN where everything from c1 to CN are
all a member of the real numbers that's
all a linear combination is let me show
you a concrete example of linear
combinations let me make the vector let
me define the vector a to be equal to
and these are all bolded these purple
these are all bolded just so those are
vectors but sometimes it's kind of
owners to keep bolding things so let's
just said to find the vector a to be
equal to 1/2 and I define the vector V
to be equal to 0-3 what is a linear
combination of a and B well I could just
I just gives you any constant times a
time plus any constant times B so it
could be it could be zero times a plus
what could be zero times a plus zero
times B which of course would be what
that would be zero times a would be zero
zero and zero zero that be the zero
vector but this is a completely valid
linear combination and we can denote the
zero vector by just a big bold zero like
that we could also this is almost I
could do three times a I'm just picking
these random these numbers at random
three times a plus we do a negative
number just for for fun so let's do plus
minus two times B what is that equal to
let's let's figure it out it's it's let
me write it out it's minus is three
minus two times zero so minus zero and
it's 3 times 2 is 6 6 minus 2 times 3 so
minus 6 so it's the vector it's the
vector 3 0 this is a linear combination
of a and B I could keep putting in a
bunch of random real numbers here and
here and I'll just get a bunch of
different linear combinations of my
vectors a and B if I had a third vector
here if I its vector C and maybe that
was just you know 7/2 then I could add
that to the mix and I could you know I
could throw in plus 8 times vector C
these are all just linear combinations
now why do we why do we you know why do
we just call them combinations why do we
have to add that little linear prefix
there because we're just scaling them up
we're not multiplying the vectors times
each other we're not we haven't even
defined what it means to multiply a
vector and there's actually several ways
to do it
but you know we can't we can't square a
vector and we don't we haven't even
defined what this means yet but this
this would all sudden make it nonlinear
in some form so all we're doing is we're
adding the vectors and we're just
scaling them up by some scaling factor
so that's why it's called a linear
linear combination now you might say hey
Sal why are you even introducing this
idea of a limit linear combination
because I want to I want to introduce
the idea and this is an idea that that
confounds most students when it's first
taught I think it's just a very nature
that it's taught over here I just kept
no I don't want to do that I just kept
putting different numbers for the
weights I guess we could call them for
you know C 1 and C 2 of this combination
of a and B right let's ignore C for a
little bit I just put in a bunch of
different numbers there but it begs the
question what is the set what is the set
of all of the vectors I could have
created and this is just one member of
that
set but what is the set of all of the
vectors I could have created by taking
linear combinations of a and B so let me
draw a and B here maybe we could think
about it visually and then maybe we
could think about it mathematically so
let's say a and B so a is 1/2 so 1/2
looks like that
that's vector a let me do a vector B in
a different column do it in yellow
vector B is 0-3 so vector B looks like
that 0 3 so what's the set of all of the
vectors that I can represent by adding
and subtracting these vectors and we saw
we could still if you multiply both by 0
and add them to each other we end up
there if we take 2 times 3 times a
that's a the equivalent of scaling up a
by 3 so you go 1 a 2 a 3 a so that's 3/8
3 times a will look like that 3 so this
vector is 3 a and then we add it to that
to be all right oh no we subtracted to
be from that so minus B looks like this
minus B looks like this minus 2 B minus
2 B looks like this this is minus 2 be
all the way in standard form standard
position minus 2 B so if you add 3 a to
minus 2 B we get to this vector 3 a to
minus 2 B you get this vector right here
and that's exactly what we did when
we've solved it mathematically you get
the vector 3 0 you get this vector right
here 3 3 0 but this was just one
combination one linear combination of a
and B I could have instead of
multiplying a times 3 I could have done
I could have multiplied a times 1 and a
half and just gotten right here so one
and a half a one and a half a minus 2 B
minus 2 B would still look the same it
would look like something like this it
would look something like it would look
let me make sure I'm doing that it would
look something like this and so our new
vector that we would find would be
something like this
so I just showed you I could find this
vector with a linear combination I could
find this vector with a linear
combination and actually turns out that
you can represent any vector in R to any
vector in r2 with some linear
combination of these vectors right here
a and B and let's just just let's just
let's just think of an example or maybe
just try to a mental visual example
wherever we want to go wherever we want
to go that we could go arbitrarily we
could scale a up by some arbitrary value
so this is some scaled up so this is
some weight on a and then we can add up
arbitrary multiples of B B goes straight
up and down so we could add up operatory
multiples of B to that so we could get
any point on this line right there now
if we scaled a up a little bit more if
we scaled up a little bit more and then
added any multiple B we get anything on
that line if we multiply a times a
negative number and then add it a B and
either direction we get anything on that
line we can keep doing that and there's
no reason why we can't pick an arbitrary
a that can fill in any of these gaps if
this is if we want to point here we just
take a little smaller a and then we can
add all the B's that fill up all of that
line so we can fill up any point in r2
with the combinations of a and B so what
we can write is what we can write here
is the span let me write this word down
the span the span of the vectors a and B
so let me write that down of the vectors
a and B it equals r2 or equals all the
vectors in r2 which is you know it's all
the tuples r2 is all the tuples made of
two ordered tuples of two real numbers
so it equals all of our two this just
means that I can represent any vector in
r2 with some linear combination of a and
B and you're like hey can't I do that
with any two vectors well what if a and
B what if a and B were the vector let's
say the vector two two was a so a is
equal to two two and let's set say that
B is the vector let's say the B is
vector minus 2 minus 2 so B is that
vector so B is the vector minus 2 minus
2 now can I represent any vector with
these well I can definitely Rep I can
scale a up and down so I can scale a up
and down to get anywhere on this line
and then I can add B or anywhere to it
and I could and B is essentially going
in the same direction it's just in the
opposite direction but I can multiply by
negative and go anywhere in line so any
combination of a and B will just end up
on this line right here if I draw it in
standard form it'll be it'll be a vector
with the same slope as either A or B or
same inclination whatever you want to
call it I could never there's no
combination of a and B that I could
represent this vector I could represent
vector C I just can't do it I can add in
standard form I could just if I just I
could just keep adding scale up a scale
up B put them heads to tails I'll just
get to stuff on this line I'll never get
to this so in this case the span and I
want to be clear this is for this
particular a and B not for the a and B
ID for this blue a and this yellow B the
span here is just this line it's just
this line it's not all of our two so
this isn't just some kind of you know
statement you might have when I first
did it with that example it's like okay
any two vectors can I represent can't
can any two vectors represent anything
in r2 well no I just showed you two
vectors can't represent that and what if
I mean you know what is the span of what
is the span of the zero vector I'll put
even a cap over the zero vector I'll
make it really bold
well the zero vector is just zero zero
so I don't care what multiple I put on
it I could put the span of it is all of
the linear combinations of this so
essentially I could put arbitrary real
numbers here but I'm just going to end
up with the zero zero vector so the span
of the zero vector is just the zero
vector the only vector I can get with a
linear combination of this the zero
vector by itself is just the zero vector
itself likewise if I take the span of
just you know let's say I go to this
let's say I go back to this example
right here are my a vector was right
like that
let me draw it in a better color my a
vector look like that if I were to ask
just what the span of a is it's all the
vectors you can get by creating a linear
combination of just a so it's really
just scaling you can't even talk about
combinations really so it's just C times
a all of those vectors and we saw on
that in that in the video where I pair
where I parametric eyes door to show the
parameter parametric representation of a
line that this the span of just this
vector a is all of the line is the line
that's formed when you just scale a up
and down so span of a is just a line you
have to have two vectors and they can't
be collinear in order to span all of our
two and I haven't proven that to you yet
but we saw with this example if you pick
this a and this B you can represent all
of our two with just these two vectors
now the two vectors that you're most
familiar with two that span r2 or if you
take a little physics class you have
your I and J unit vectors I and J I and
J and in our notation I the unit vector
I that you learn in physics class would
be the vector 1 0 so this is I that's
the vector I and then the vector J is
the unit vector 0 1 this is what you
learned in physics class let me do a
different color this is j j is that and
you learned that they're orthogonal and
we're going to talk a lot more about
what orthogonal t means but in our in
our traditional sense that we learn in
high school it means that they're 90
degrees but you can clearly represent
any angle or any any vector in r2 by
these two vectors and the fact that
they're orthogonal makes them extra nice
and that's why these form and i'm going
to throw out a word here that i haven't
defined yet these forms the basis these
form a basis for r2 and that in that you
can represent anything in r2 by these
two vectors long I'm not going to even
define what basis is that's going to be
a future video but let me make let me
just write the formal math you
definition of span just so you're
satisfied so if I were to write the span
the span of a set of vectors V 1
v2 all the way to VN that just means the
set the set of all of the vectors where
I have c1 times v1 plus c2 times v2 all
the way to CN let me scroll over all the
way to CN VN so this is a set of vectors
because there I can pick my C eyes to be
any member of the real numbers and
where's you know and that's true for i
from so I should write for I being
anywhere between 1 and n all I'm saying
is is that look each I can multiply each
of these vectors by any value any
arbitrary value real value and then I
can add them up and now the set of all
of the combinations scaled up
combinations I can get that's the span
that's the span of these vectors you can
kind of view it as the space of all of
the vectors that can be represented by a
combination of these vectors right there
and so the word span I think it does
have an intuitive sense I mean it all if
I if I say that you know my first
example I sold those two vectors span or
a and B spans are - I wrote it right
here that tells me that any vector in r2
can be represented can be represented by
a linear combination of a and B and
actually just in case that visual kind
of pseudo proof doesn't do you justice
let me prove it to you algebraically I'm
telling you that I can take let's say I
want to represent you know I have some
let me rewrite my A's and B's again so
this was my vector a it was one two and
B was 0 3 let me remember that so my
vector a a is 1 2 and my vector B was 0
3 now my claim was that I can represent
any point let's say I want to represent
some arbitrary point X in R 2 so its
coordinates are X 1 and X 2
I need to be able to prove to you that I
can get to any x1 and any x2 with some
combination of these guys so let's say
that my combination I say I say c1 times
a plus c2 times B has to be equal to my
vector X so let me show you that I can
always find a c1 or c2 given that you
give me some X's so let's just write
this right here with the actual vectors
being represented in their kind of
column form so we have c1 times this
vector plus c2 times the B vector zero
three should be able to be equal my X
vector should be able to be equal to my
x1 and x2 where these are just arbitrary
so let's see if I can set that to be
true so if this is true then the
following must be true c1 c1 times 1
plus 0 times c2 must be equal to x1 we
just get that from our definition of
multiplying vectors time scalars and
adding vectors and then we also know
that 2 times c2 2 times c2 or C sorry 2
times C 1 times 2 C 1 times 2 plus C 2
times 3 3 C 2 should be equal to x2 now
if I can show you that I can always find
C 1 s and C 2 is given any X's and any X
1 and X 2 s then I've proven that I can
get to any point in r2 using just these
two vectors so let me see if I can do
that so this is just a 2 to unknown a
system of two unknowns this is just 0 we
can ignore it so let's multiply this
equation up here by -2 and put it two
here so we get minus 2 C 1 I'm just
multiplying this times -2 we get a 0
here plus 0 is equal to minus 2 X 1 and
then you add these 2 you get 3 C 2 right
these cancel out you
three let me write in a different color
you get 3 C 2 is equal to X 2 minus 2 X
1 or divide both sides by 3 you get C 2
is equal to 1/3 X 2 minus X 1 now we'd
have to go substitute back in for for C
1 well we have this first equation right
here that's C 1 this first equation is
it says C 1 plus 0 is equal to X 1 so C
1 is equal to X 1 so that one just gets
us there so C 1 is equal to X 1 so you
give me any point in R 2 these are just
two real numbers and I can just perform
this operation and I'll tell you what
waits to apply to a and B to get to that
point if you say ok what combination of
a and B can get me to the point let's
say I want to get to the point let me go
back up here so well it's way up there
let's say I'm looking to get to the
point 2 2 so X 1 is 2
let me write it down here say I'm trying
to get to the point the vector 2 2 what
combinations of a and B can be there
well I know that C 1 is equal to X 1 so
that's equal to 2 and C 2 is equal to
1/3 times 2 minus 2 so C so 2 2 minus 2
is 0 so C 2 is equal to 0 so if I want
to just get to the point 2 2 I just
multiply oh I just realized this was
looking suspicious I made a slight error
here and this was good that I actually
tried it out with real numbers over here
when I had 3 C 2 is equal to X 2 minus 2
X 1 I got rid of this 2 of over here
there's a 2 over here I divide both
sides by 3 I get 1/3 times X 2 minus 2 X
1 and that's why I was like why this
doesn't list this this is looking
strange not to take a moment of pause so
let's go to my my my corrected
definition of C 2 C 2 is equal to 1/3
times X 2 so 2 minus 2 times X 1 so
minus 2 times 2
so it's equal to 1/3 times 2 minus 4 2
minus 4 which is equal to minus 2 s is
equal to minus 2/3 so if I multiply so
if I multiply 2 2 times my vector a
minus 2/3 times my vector B I will get
to the vector 2 2 and you can verify it
to your for yourself 2 times 2 times my
vector a 1 2 minus 2/3 times my vector B
0 3 should equal to 2